so first question about your script here
what would you say was the break story
moment the idea that came to you that
made you think we have something special
here and it's time to move on it um so
it's an idea that I've had for kind of a
while um it's based on my older brother
who is a Jeopardy whiz and all growing
up it was extremely frustrating to try
to play Jeopardy alongside of him and
just be destroyed um but he's so smart
and he it's been his dream to get on
Jeopardy he's auditioned so many times
and he always makes it into the
contestant pool but never gets the call
to go on the show and when I first moved
to LA I was working as an assistant on a
Sony TV show and so I would have to
drive onto the Sony lot all the time and
I would drive past the Jeopardy stage
and I was just like it's right there if
I could just get my brother onto
Jeopardy it would make his whole life um
so that was the initial idea and then I
just kept circling back to it and just
being like I feel like that's such a fun
jumping off point for a story about you
know two arang siblings coming back
together has he still not been on
Jeopardy no can you believe that I'm
like I don't even know him and I'm
already very invested in this how do I
campaign to get him on Jeopardy I really
am just like if this movie winds up just
being like the the way to get him on
Jeopardy I mean nothing will make me
happier I mean I'm here to do whatever I
can to make that happen so you've had
you've had this idea for a good while
now what would you say is the biggest
difference between draft one of this
screenplay and now what everyone's going
to see in the final film um oh my gosh
great question I think um the characters
really just have evolved so much once we
got Aquafina and Sandra o on board it
was so fun to really craft these
characters with them they had so many
great ideas and they just were so
excited to really throw themselves into
this and um my very PR pentious uh
metaphor for writing characters is that
it's like uh sculpting a statue where
it's like the writer just on their own
just kind of like makes the rough shape
and then the actor and the director come
in and you sort of like do all the fine
detail work together and it's so fun to
just sort of uncover this character as
it comes to life and so I think just the
central two characters are the things
that change the most because they really
they wouldn't be who they are if it
weren't for Aquafina and Sandra all
right one of uh one of my follow-up
questions to that is one of my absolute
favorites because I love talking about
how things can evolve through every
single step of the film making process
so is there anything in the final film
that you wound up loving more than you
ever expected where someone who's
involved in the making of quiz lady did
something with it that I don't know I
guess maybe made you realize that
something in your own script was even
stronger than you ever thought it was I
mean the there were so many moments I
really just like nothing Delights me
more than um when you you really get a
sense of how many people work on a movie
and how excited they are and their
individual skill sets and what they
bring to it and one of the moments I
think about a lot is when uh we were
shooting the audition scenes in the
hotel and Jeff man the production
designer was just like hey come take a
look at this and he showed me that they
had printed up signs for um an egg
donation like
just charity I think it's just like it's
that's the conference that's going on
it's like about egg donation and that's
just based on one throwaway joke from
later on in the script but he was just
like I thought it would be funny to put
this sign back here it's the type of
thing that no one will ever notice like
maybe on your Third Watch you'll notice
this sign in the background but stuff
like that I just love so much because
it's just the movie you know every
aspect of this movie Just Delights me to
no end um because it really just
represents so much love and hard work
from hundreds of people and they did
such a great job I will preface this
question by saying it is very very
unfair and every single person who
worked on this movie matters but can you
maybe name one person that you know
they're not the star of the movie
they're not the right of producer or a
director but someone that we need to
know their name because of how heavily
they contributed to making this
something special oh my gosh I mean
Casey Goodell was our first ad and she
was incredible that is the hardest job I
think on set um ads always deserve more
credit always some Heroes yeah we would
be nowhere without them we would be
behind we would still be on set we would
never rap um but yeah that job is
extremely difficult and it's also very
difficult to do um you know without
people just like really hating you
because you have to be such a Taskmaster
but Casey was so incredible and she
really you know contributed to so much
to that set running so well and just
making it so that everyone was able to
do their jobs really well so she was the
unsung hero for sure I love hearing
about a good ad all right here's a part
of the process that I am always eager to
shine a light on but especially after
coming out of the recent writer strike
what is it mean to you to be both a
writer and producer on a project and
maybe also what value do you think it
brings to a project when a writer's work
does not stop with just writing the
script but they are involved throughout
a production totally um I love that you
asked that question thank you so much um
yeah it was huge I mean I I was so
grateful that I really got to be
involved through every step of the way
like I was on set in New Orleans I lived
there for the whole time and uh got to
be you know on set every day I was
really involved with post um and it's
such a gift because I think you know
it's so hard to kind of Define what
screenwriting is because it's not just
just typing it's it's everything it's
storytelling and that happens you know
throughout the entire process like you
you know editing a movie is just writing
a movie visually again so you know
there's so much stuff that you can
uncover and I think you know writers can
also be a big asset on set you know
there are times where it's just like
something goes wrong you know like oh
there's something wrong with this
location or like oh the crane broke and
so we can't do this thing now um and if
you have the writer there you know they
can help in the solution because it's
like okay we might not be able to
accomplish this exactly as we saw it but
the story intent could be accomplished
this way instead so you might actually
wind up saving time and money by not
just sort of being stuck to the script
like there's ways to sort of accomplish
what you need to accomplish by rewriting
it as you're going um and so that was so
incredible to be able to be a part of it
and be a part of you know solving the
problems that come up and finding
Creative Solutions for you know all of
the many snags that movies will
naturally run into so so true something
I will always continue to highlight all
right I'm gonna follow up that serious
question with some sillier lighter stuff
first I am obsessed with dogs so I need
to know everything about Mr Linguini
first was Mr Linguini always scripted to
be a pug yes so Mr Linguini I'm also
obsessed with dogs as you probably could
assume um Mr Linguini is based on my
very good friends uh they have a pug
named Aggie um it's short for agodor
Spartacus they named her after Hanka
are's character from The Bird Cage um
and Aggie she's now 11 she's a grand old
Dame uh but I love her so much and she
just always makes me laugh because just
the sound of a pug
snoring there's nothing funnier more
disruptive or more soothing like it's
it's all three um and so she just really
made me laugh and then yeah in thinking
of an as this character who's really
turned Inward and like shut herself off
from the world um I thought that a pug
is just the perfect companion for her
because in many ways I think of an as
someone who was raised by TV so she has
the personality of Terry mctier so like
she was a y old girl with the
personality of a 40-year-old man and I
feel like that's what a pug is like
they're these adorable little puppies
but they're so just old and and World
weary there is nothing more relatable
than a young adult raised by TV who also
like fills a hole in her heart with with
a dog yeah I mean that's literally me so
I know I share that too wait in that
case who who is uh who is your dog
what's your dog named after um so my dog
is named Wall-E his full name is Walnut
um I have a Wall-E really I swear named
after Wall-E from pixars movie we were
also like we want to name him walnet
we'll call him Wall-E it's sort of after
Wall-E because we love that movie what
kind of dog is he Wall-E is a mini daxon
a white mini Doxon so very unusual
looking and he is a sweetheart wait what
what type of dog is your w-e we think
he's like a multi poo um when we got him
they were like we think he'll be 40 lbs
and we were like like great perfect and
then he tapped out at 12 and we were
just like great we have this little
fluff but we love him so much he uh my
husband and I frequently refer to him as
our boss um he really makes all the
sense in the world to me yeah all of our
pets should always run our lives that is
how I operate at least um some silly
game show questions for you now what
game show do you think you would be best
at but then I also want the opposite the
the reality TV show competition show
that you would never ever want to be on
because you would stink at it oh my gosh
I mean I I love Survivor and it's my
dream to go on Survivor but I would
never do it um because I mean I think it
would drive me insane but also I'm not a
very strong swimmer and I live in fear
of being like on some fail compilation
video of like me belly flopping into the
ocean so I would never go on Survivor
even though I want to um and I feel
like I really want to go on Jeopardy I
feel like I could be good at it but I'm
also so scared that I would choke and
look stupid um but I do love trivia so
much so I kind of feel like I could be
okay but I don't know and I'll never
know because my brother has to get on
and then that'll be enough I feel like I
would be good at Jeopardy like one out
of every five days of the week exactly
that's how I feel I'm like it would be
so dependent on if I could do well or if
I would just be so catastrophically I
would be the Mary Beth windmore I would
just completely
freeze yeah get scared I might be that
as well all right I have to wind down
with you so the inevitable is going to
happen I have to squeeze in a couple of
Hocus Pocus 3 questions because I love
Halloween I love that movie and now that
franchise first a safe question for you
or at least what I think is a safe
question it is obviously hugely exciting
to get to continue on with a franchise
and saying yes to writing another script
had to be a no-brainer but what about
for you as a writer evolving your craft
is there anything about Hocus Pocus 3
that makes you think this is the next
best step for me in order to you know
add more skills to my toolkit yeah I
mean I think it's it's such an
interesting challenge I mean I think
with Hocus Pocus 2 you know you had the
challenge of revisiting these beloved
characters and you know wanting to
really make it um worthwhile this Sequel
and um I feel like you know we had so
much fun making it it turned out so well
I'm so I'm so thrilled and honored and
humbled by the response that it got and
so it's so exciting to be able to go do
a third one but it is you know it's its
own new challenge of kind of like well
now we have different expectations going
into this and people you know that fan
base is so devoted as as am I I am just
as much a fan as everybody else so I'm
like yes I have my own theories about
what we could see and what things mean
and where we could take these characters
so uh it's interesting to be like okay
now we have even more possibility and
it'll be a challenge to sort of pick the
Avenue and really make the movie stand
on its own I have a feeling you'll Crush
that challenge I love the second one
quite a bit and that's coming from like
my version of Terry is the Sanderson
sisters like they taught me how to be a
person growing up yes I watch it every
Halloween like I loved it so much it was
so it's it's a part of me it's a part of
my D Focus Pocus Nightmare Before
Christmas and trick-or treat essential
essential all right now I'm going to
squeeze in a question that I feel like
you're not going to be able to answer
but I'm at least going to try so
assuming we have not seen the last of
the Sanderson sisters do you think that
wiford can still be like like de
devilishly delightful but also still
reflect the fact that she actually
learned something at the end of the
second movie oh totally because I think
you know with the Sanderson sisters the
thing that makes them so fun is that
they really are like hurting cats so I'm
like yes winter Fred learned a very
valuable lesson she loves her sisters
more than anything in the world but she
will also just immediately get
distracted by whatever is put in front
of her so if you dangle the carrot of a
potential revenge against Salem which
she has always wanted you know she might
uh have a backslide where she uh you
know gets singularly focused on the
wrong goal again um I think that's
totally possible yeah I look forward to
hearing more about that and until then I
am happy to watch and rewatch quiz over
and over and over again seriously
delightful movie huge congratulations to
you thank you so
much